in this video we're going to go through
two examples where we write the equation
of a quadratic and so we're given a
table and we want to try to establish
now is this a quadratic function and how
do we find the a b and c values so that
we can write it in that standard form of
a quadratic so the first thing we want
to do is notice how these X values are
increasing by one each time we can use a
method called finite differences to
figure out whether this is a first
degree second degree third degree
polynomial Etc and the way you would do
that is you would subtract these y
values and what I like to do is you want
to make sure you're consistent either do
the right minus the Left Right minus the
Left Right minus left like that or left
minus right left minus right but you
want to stay consistent I always do the
right minus the left so 5 minus 11 comes
out to negative six three minus 5 is
negative two five minus 3 is 2 and 11
minus 5 is 6. now if this was a linear
equation these would all be the same
number it would be going up at a
constant rate but in this case it wasn't
a constant number let's see if we can
subtract again negative two minus
negative six is four two minus negative
two is four and six minus 2 is 4. so see
how we're getting the same number it
doesn't matter what the number is it's
just that on the second time that we
subtracted that second order difference
tells us that this is a second degree
polynomial a quadratic
polynomial so what we're going to do
here is now we're going to find out what
are the a b and c values and the way
we're going to do that is we're going to
write a system of equations so let's go
ahead and take a few of these points
let's say for example this point this
point and this point so if Y is 3 when x
is 0 so let's do that so when Y is 3
when X is zero
zero squared is zero times a is zero
B times zero is zero and we have C and
so now you can see that c is equal to
three okay so now we know what c is how
do we solve for A and B well let's go
ahead and take this other point here
let's say when Y is 5 x is one so five
equals a times 1 squared plus b times 1
plus C but in this case I'm going to put
3 in for C here so that's one equation
we can solve for A and B but when we
have two variables we need two equations
so let's go ahead and take this other
point here when Y is 11 X is two so this
is a times 2 squared plus b times 2 plus
C which C here is three so now if we
simplify let's see what we get here we
get 1 squared is one times a is a so
let's write that down plus b times 1 is
B
okay plus three now I'm going to
subtract the 3 to the other side so
that's going to be equal to 5 minus 3
which is two and then for this equation
let's see 4 squared 2 squared is 4 times
a is 4A
and 2 times B is 2b
and the 3 I'm going to subtract over
that's eight so this is going to equal
8. so now we've got our two equations
two variables we just have to solve for
A and B If I multiply this top equation
by negative 2 that's going to make this
negative 2B when we add it to this
positive 2B the B's are going to cancel
so let's go ahead and do that so this is
going to be negative 2A minus 2B equals
negative 4 and this equation we're going
to keep the same so that's 4A
plus 2B is equal to 8.
and now when we add you can see the B's
cancel and we have 2A
is equal to 4. so if we divide both
sides by 2 you can see that a is equal
to 2.
now all we have to do is plug this 2
back into any one of these two variable
equations let's just do this one so 2
plus b is equal to 2. if we subtract 2
from both sides you can see that b is
equal to zero
so now if we put it all back together we
have y is equal to a which is 2 B which
is 0 and C is equal to 3 and we've got
our quadratic equation now sometimes I
like to check it I might pick another
number say for example when X is
negative 1 does y equal 5 and yes it
looks like it does so I just want to
double check let's look at another
example see if you can pause the video
and do this example number two on your
own we'll go through it together just so
you get a little bit of practice
we've got this table here and we notice
that the X values are going up at a
consistent rate here they're going up by
one each time so let's look at the
change in the Y values so if I do Y2
minus y1 here the second y minus this
first y I get 7. 23 minus 14 is 9. 34
minus 23 is 11 and 47 minus 34 is 13.
now we don't get that same number so
it's not a first degree equation it's
not when we get that first order
difference to be the same that's like a
first degree it's not so in this case
let's subtract a second time again
staying consistent right minus left 9
minus 7 is 2 11 minus 9 is 2 and 13
minus 11 is 2. now notice we're getting
the same number the second time that we
subtract that tells us it's a second
degree equation and so we can write
our quadratic equation here in this form
but we have to figure out what our a B
and C are so that means if we have three
variables we need three equations right
so let's go ahead and use these three
points right here it doesn't matter
which points you use you can use the
three four and five or any any pair any
three
so let's start with this one so when Y
is 7
uh X is one so that's going to be a
times x squared x squared of course is
just going to be 1 squared which is 1
plus b times 1. here I'll put the
squared here and then plus C so that's
one equation and let's go to the next
point so when Y is 14 x is 2 so that's 2
squared plus b times 2 plus C and then
let's take this one when Y is 23
let's see X is 3 so that's 3 squared
plus b times 3 plus C okay so three
variables three equations let's see if
we can simplify these a little bit
further here
a 1 squared we know is 1 and 2 squared
is 4 and 3 squared is 9. so let's just
rewrite this a little bit let me put
them over here we've got a plus b plus C
is equal to 7.
4A plus 2B plus C is equal to 14 and
let's see 9A
plus 3B
plus C is equal to 23. now what we have
to do is we have to pick a variable to
eliminate these are the A's the B's or
the C's I think it's going to be easiest
to eliminate the C's because they're all
the same they're 1C so let's say for
example if I take this equation the
middle one and I subtract the first one
so 4A minus 1A is going to give us 3A
I'll put it right here and 2B minus 1B
is 1B and C minus C is 0 and 14 minus 7
is 7. okay so I use the first and second
equation I have to use the third
equation I can combine it with the
second or I can combine it with the
first either way it doesn't matter but
we have to try to eliminate that same
variable that c so I'm going to do the
third minus the second so 9A minus 4A
gives us 5A 3B minus 2B gives us 1B and
C minus C is 0 and 23 minus 14 is 9.
okay so now we're down to two variables
two equations and we want to eliminate
either the A's or the B's it looks like
the B's are going to be the easiest here
let's just go ahead and take the bottom
equation and we'll subtract the top
equation so 5A minus 3A is 2A B minus B
is 0 and 9 minus 7 is 2. so if we divide
both sides by 2 you can see that a is
coming out to 1. so now we went from
three variables three equations to two
variables two equations to one variable
one equation now we wanna work our way
backwards and back substitute so if a is
one let's put it right here 3 times 1 is
3 so we have three plus b is equal to
seven subtract 3 from both sides
you can see that b is coming out to four
and now we need to solve for C let's use
this top equation a plus b plus C equals
seven so that comes out to one
plus four plus C equals seven so if this
is five If I subtract 5 C is equal to
two so now we've got our a b and c we
can plug it into our equation here we've
got y equals a which is one so this is
just one x squared
plus b which is 4 so plus 4X plus C
which is equal to two and that's our
equation in standard form or quadratic
again I like to check it sometimes just
to see if I'm on the right track so
let's see maybe let's pick this point
here so if Y is 34 when X is 4 is that
true 4 squared is 16 plus 4 times 4 is
16 that's 32 plus two more is 34. yes it
matches so looks like we're good on that
one so great job if you're able to do
that prom I'll put a video right there
involving additional problems that are
similar to these if you want some
additional practice so follow me over to
that video right there and we'll get
some additional practice I'll see you
over there